[Inaudible].
Far left. Lunacy is hitting every corner, though. New radical,
extreme democratic party.
Look at the city of San Francisco handling the pandemic.
They given out free drugs and alcohol and weed and cigarettes to homeless
people to help them stay quarantine, Congressman a Casio,
Cortez she's outraged or fainting. It slamming jet blue.
They did a New York city fly over honoring first responders and frontline
healthcare workers tweeting out nothing like a corporate PR campaign that
burns jet fuel at low altitudes over vulnerable communities,
dying from a respiratory virus, uh,
Congresswoman one of you as Nancy Pelosi,
how she goes back and forth from San Francisco and whether or not she uses a
private jet. Ask her that here with reaction author of don't burn this book,
Dave Rubin, Salem nationally syndicated radio host, Larry elder, Mr. Rubin,
really weed booze cigarettes.
Maybe I want to be homeless cause I probably could use all of them at this
point. Not that I use drugs.
Sean, they're really onto something up there. I mean,
let me get this straight so you can get drunk. Then you can get stoned.
Then you get the munchies.
Then you swing on over to Pelosi's for some ice cream. I mean,
I think San Francisco has got some sort of new economic thing working out right
now, but the whole things, of course it's nuts. Look my good friend,
Larry elder and I were here in Los Angeles. I mean, quite literally,
I can't bring a bottle of wine to Larry's house, house and us have a drink,
but we're going to give booze and weed to homeless people.
I'm not even against booze and weed. Okay. But it's just crazy.
This is just typical San Francisco stuff. Larry.
I don't think I could have made this up.
You really can't but this is California Shaun. This is,
this is a one party state there isn't a single Republican who holds an office
statewide. They've gotten majority.
It's not just majorities in both houses of the legislature. Sean,
they've got super majorities.
This is a town that gives elite a state that gives illegal aliens.
In-state tuition. Something that your kid couldn't get.
If your kid got into UCLA or USC.
So why should anybody be surprised you can deprecate in the streets and in
California,
as long as you're not cutting it clutching a bunch of banned plastic straws.
You're good to go.
Make sure you're wearing your face mask while you're doing it.
Yeah. All right. So what happens? You just get online.
How do you get your free weed, booze and cigarettes? Uh, the, uh, Ms. Dave,
how do we do that?
I love that. I love that concept. It's like,
do you have to prove you're homeless somehow? I mean,
I thought these are the same people that are against IDs.
How do you prove you're homeless?
So you can show up to get the weed and the booze. I mean,
none of it makes sense, but it's so consistent with progressive policies.
I mean, look Gavin, who's our governor here. I mean, elder,
we gotta get out of here.
Can we talk after the show we got to get out of this state.
You guys got to get out of there, man. We shouldn't be surprised.
I've got to get out of, Oh, let's see.
And the COVID patients to nursing homes to infect everybody. That's vulnerable.
That's the state I live in Larry. Last word. Absolutely.
This, this is where we are. Uh, my, my two-step solution, the same California.
Sean, keep the illegal aliens, deport the Democrats.
All right, go run. Thank you. Both. Congrats on the book, Dave.
Well,
if you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlists, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.